Yeah.
Hey,
what's going on?
It's bill burn.
It's time for the Monday morning podcast for Monday,
September 19th,
2016 what's going on?
How are you?
How are you doing this morning?
How was your day?
Did you make it through another one with nothing to stay
fucking boss?
Come walking in.
Hey Carl,
could that gave a word with you and go fuck yourself now when she just love to
be able to say,
yeah,
no doubt.
I'm not saying you're not my boss,
but just not today.
All right?
Come with me late Tuesday.
Maybe Wednesday.
Tell you what,
I'll meet here Wednesday for lunch.
All right,
fucking have a word with me Monday morning.
You can't.
All right.
I'm still coming off the high of being free for a couple of days.
You know,
that's where the great thing about Saturday and Sunday,
if you do it right,
meaning you know you're living within your means so you're not stressing about
bills.
It didn't have any fucking kids,
so you got no responsibility on that.
Saturday and Sunday,
you actually get to feel what it's like to be a trust fund kid.
You know,
that's what being a trust fund kid is.
Every day is a Saturday or a Sunday.
You know what,
just limitless possibilities.
I'm going to do this,
I'm going to do that.
Hey,
I'm not gonna do shit.
It's phenomenal,
you know?
So anyways,
um,
I fucking got up,
uh,
I got up this morning,
but I do bad.
Oh boob and I had to go feed my dog,
right.
Had to take the thing outside.
So I did all of that when I was done,
you know,
the usual thing.
Um,
this little house that we rented,
little cute little cottage or they fixing enough fucking kitchen in.
These guys are moving right along,
which I'm psyched about.
You know,
they took the whole fucking kitchen out and then I was on the road for a couple
of days.
I came back and they have all the plumbing done,
um,
which is fucking great.
They got all the copper wa a copper pipes done and um,
you know,
got rid of all the galvanized pipe.
Psyched about that.
And,
um,
for whatever reason,
you know,
our sink was just facing cabinets.
It was like cabinets right above the sink.
He just like wash dishes,
you know,
staring into the cabinet.
So he go think about the cabinet say was when my lower back was bugging me,
I could rest my fucking flatscreen TV forehead against the,
uh,
against the cabinet.
Give it a little bit of relief.
But you know the deal,
this sink is supposed to be near the window.
That's the classic style for like,
it was for women back in the day when they weren't allowed to vote or basically
leave the house,
you know,
for all extensive purposes.
So they to just as they wash the dishes,
they could just look out,
you know,
and dream the dreams that they were never going to live.
You know?
And I just think it's nice that after all these years,
the Emmy's finally stepped up and gave everybody else in award.
Jason is,
my wife was watching that thing last night.
What a fucking shit show.
I don't know,
man.
I gotta tell you something.
There's no way that it's worse for someone who is into watching award shows our
award show to make them watch sports.
There's no way that that's a worse experience than someone who watches sports.
Having to sit there and watch a fucking,
the Emmy's,
you know,
I didn't have to sit there.
I kinda had a dad too because uh,
you know,
I didn't see my wife and a couple of days and she was like,
I want to hang out with you.
And then we had to sit there and just watch these fucking things.
It just,
Ugh,
the actress.
It just so God damn dramatic
because you believed in me.
I dared to try.
Okay.
I almost fucking threw up whoever the hell said that because you believed in me.
I dared to try.
It's like you're a fucking actor.
It's a killer script.
You what?
You're going to turn it down.
That fucking Oj mini series was,
was unbelievable.
Okay.
I don't believe in me,
but because you did,
I dared,
I dared to try.
Ugh.
It was one of the worst things I've ever heard,
you know,
other than when you call up the cable company,
if you learn to do,
when you get into that,
talking to a robot lady is one notch lower than that.
I'm not shitting on the actor.
You know what I mean?
They get God because they liked that.
That's why they give the great performance isn't because I'm a cunt.
That's why I do stand up.
You know what I mean?
So everybody finds the little fucking hole is supposed to crawl into,
oh my God,
there's always,
these are,
these are important stories and they need to be told,
just take his shiny thing and leaf,
just give us the keys.
Ah,
oh my God.
Dot.
My wife had me over a barrel because I,
you know,
I've been away for like three,
four days.
And um,
and then I came home and she was out with,
uh,
with my brother and my own,
my sister in law,
my niece.
So it's fucking place where I was staying at.
They don't have the fucking NFL package.
What kind of a fuck man doesn't have the NFL package.
Okay.
I don't give a shit.
If your kid has the mumps,
you see,
you carve about something out of your budget.
All right.
To have the fucking NFL package.
So I'm sitting there going like,
fuck,
how do I know I can watch it?
I know I can watch it on my computer.
So there's no adult.
There are child who's kidding who to help me navigate the SIG.
So I go onto the fucking direct TV thing.
I sign up for something for 99 bucks and I did it and I was like,
oh my God,
I did it.
And uh,
you know,
patriots dolphins,
I want to see this.
I missed the first half and whatever I signed up for was to get the radio feed
cost me like 99 bucks to listen to it on the radio.
What,
what am I a fucking world?
Whoa.
One fighter pilot.
Ah,
what am,
what am I some guy from a time before TV,
sorry,
sorry for the bad reference there.
I mean,
what the fuck?
I'm not 80 right.
So now I'm trying to figure out how to get the video while I have the game on
the radio.
And all I'm hearing is that Garappolo fades back to pass and this guy was coming
at him for like 10 yards and he's,
I evidently he stood there like Steve Grogan until the last second stay on
target and then he let it go.
I still haven't seen the replay and I guess he got picked up and slammed to the
ground and uh,
you know,
I guess he fucked up his shoulder.
I have no idea.
So now they've got this other guy coming in for an NC state.
The place I went to for two semesters,
way back in the day.
Um,
okay.
And they proceed to March right down the field.
So anyways,
long story short.
So I ended up having a call up direct TV,
right.
And I get into that fucking nightmare,
you know.
Thank you for calling.
Do Reg TV.
If you calling about a paper review that you already already press one.
If you killing without when you to one order press two and then right there I
sit there and you got to make that thing okay.
If I call up and say I already ordered it,
that means they already have my money so I know I'm going to be on hold longer.
So I always go with the second option acting as though that I want to order
something now because that will get you to a person immediately like,
cause I just feel like they're like,
oh we don't have this fucking Parsons number yet.
So always picked that option.
But for whatever fucking reason,
you know,
I picked the first option,
I decided not to lie and then I got dragged into this whole thing and,
but I'm just trying to stay calm.
You know?
Patience is a virtue.
As old I said this to me when I was in Charlotte,
North Carolina,
we both sitting in a bag and I was off trying to do something.
It was a Saturday.
There was a bunch of fucking people there.
I know I had to wire money to get this fucking place because the last people
fucked us over on the other place and the people coming to fix this,
the kitchen and we had to be out of there and it was Saturday.
And you know,
Saturday,
you don't want to go to a bank on Saturday.
That's when nobody who has their money right shows up on a fucking Saturday.
Right?
And they just sit there like,
like,
like children
trying to figure out,
you know,
that whatever 100 minus 110 means negative 10 and you have no fucking money and
you owe the money back and up the bank money,
right?
So I was just sitting there going,
okay,
and this guy was like a preacher or something like that,
this older dude.
And he just,
and I could tell he was frustrating.
He just said out loud page.
He's like,
uh,
patience is a virtue.
And I've,
I've been hanging onto that white knuckling it to that.
So I'm sitting there trying to navigate this fucking robot system,
knowing,
knowing I know how this story ends.
It's Charlie Brown trying to kick the football.
I know it's not going to happen,
but I'm trying to channel my wife's calm,
relaxed energy.
I'm trying to channel this fucking guy and I'm just answering all the questions
and you know what?
All of a sudden,
you know,
I'm not knocking down the hurdles.
I'm clearing them.
Okay,
I'm getting out in front of this fucking race.
I can see the finish line.
Right.
I clear the last fucking hurdle and all of a sudden I forget what the fucking
thing was.
It's like if you just,
if you want to sign up,
no,
no.
It finally got two if you would like to speak.
I think I went,
the last one was,
but it was the last thing I had to do.
It's like say yes and I was like,
oh my God,
I did it.
And I went,
yes,
in this fucking thing.
Does system heard the other 80 fucking questions it asked,
I had to keep hitting mute to go ah,
yeah,
fucking con and then unmute it because if you yell all your fucking can intuit.
The robot goes,
I'm sorry I didn't understand.
And then you got to go back to the beginning.
So I got my fucking new game is down so I get the fucking anger out.
And then I just kept going pleasantly.
I'd be like,
you know,
uh,
order NFL on my computer.
Yeah.
And then it asks another question.
I'd be like,
yeah,
just quite somebody's on mute.
How many fucking questions you gotta ask?
Wait and then unmute.
It'd be like,
yes.
So I answered it all.
Fucking 18 of the questions.
Yeah.
Alright.
And the last one was basically it was 10 like is so this is what you want to do.
And I just go,
yes.
And the thing all of a sudden just goes,
I'm sorry I didn't understand.
And then starts asking the question and I immediately start panic,
panicking as it's asking the question,
I'm going to guess yes.
Right.
And it fucking stops,
you know,
just,
if this is what you want to do,
say yes.
If not,
say no.
And then I was like,
yes.
And then this is just excruciating second pause and it comes back on and goes,
I'm sorry I didn't understand that.
I just went,
yes,
it is empty.
Fucking rub,
like a complete lunatic.
And of course it didn't hear me.
And then I just started yelling,
operator,
person,
you fucking cunt.
And I finally hit zero.
Okay.
Because a lot of them don't have that option anymore.
I hit zero and it actually took me,
you know,
it put me on hold and now I'm like,
oh my God.
It was just like,
uh,
you know,
now I was on hold and then I'm thinking like,
oh my God,
I want to be on hold forever.
It's football every fucking 48 year old and above fucking dude like me who blew
off computers.
This is my only,
I blew this shit off.
I remember I was living with Bobby Kelly and he totally embraced computers.
The fucking guy can like,
you know,
he can go into the dark web if he wants to.
He knows what the fuck he's doing.
I was just like,
these things are fucking stupid.
Give me a notebook and a pen.
I'm going to go churn some fucking butter in here.
Right.
Um,
and I'm still paying the price,
so I'm on hold for fucking ever as,
um,
you know,
but it's halftime and,
uh,
the Patriots somehow are up like,
I dunno,
20 something to like three and a,
I guess go Rapo looked,
looked fucking amazing.
So
as I'm on hold for like 20 minutes,
that computer can't keeps coming back going,
you know,
basically said you're going to be on hold for a long time,
but it's a lot easier.
It's a lot easy and more exciting if you go to our website and it's like,
fuck you,
I don't work for you.
You know?
Plus the reality is I can't figure it out.
Um,
so finally this woman comes on
after like a half hour and she's just like,
hey,
how you doing?
Thanks for calling direct TV.
We have a pleasant day,
but blah,
blah,
blah.
She said,
great energy.
She goes,
she just goes basic.
What's the problem?
I was like,
the problems of 48 years old.
I blown off computers and I don't know how to,
I just want to watch the game on my device.
And she laughed and she goes,
all right,
what's the name on the account?
She types that in.
She goes,
all right,
you need to get the NFL plus things and I can watch it on your iPhone,
all of this and blah,
blah,
blah.
We figured all of that out and I was like,
well,
she goes to,
then he'd just go to this and I go,
don't leave me.
You just got to walk me through the whole thing.
She laughed.
She walked me through the whole thing.
It took like three minutes.
It was incredible.
Like
there's nothing better than getting a fucking person.
They totally help you out unless you get a jerk.
But she wasn't.
She was an angel.
And next thing you know,
I got the game and um,
be on site and I got to watch the whole second half of the,
uh,
of the Patriot game when the dude from NC state came in.
Wait a second,
let's see,
what's his name?
Patriots and see State Qb.
Um,
what's his name?
Oh,
Jacoby preset came in and did a great job.
He marches right down the field.
We go up like fucking 35 to fucking three or 10 or whatever the fuck it was at
that point.
34 was that what it was?
31 31 that's what it was.
It was 31,
two
till I 10 or some shit like that.
And I'm just like,
oh,
this is fucking great.
This is great.
We got
it.
We can cruise now.
And then all of a sudden the dolphins just start coming back.
You know,
they start marching right down the fucking field and it's just like the classic
NFL.
It's likeK is any lead big enough.
I know that we got our third string quarterback who's now a second string
because Tom Brady is an active,
what the fuck?
Blah,
blah,
blah blah.
But um,
long story short,
we ended up pulling out the,
when we're fucking two and oh,
and guess who lost again?
The Cultch lost again.
Can you believe this?
You know,
it's almost like the football gods are,
are weighing in.
I feel the fact that we're two window without our starting quarterback,
without our second string,
with our third string,
we win.
You know,
granted we played the fucking dolphins,
you know,
they're uh,
okay.
They weren't awake right now obviously,
you know,
so
I dunno,
I'm just,
I'm so fucking site,
I'm telling you right now if we go through,
you know,
okay.
And the colts go all in for I know I schedule is going to get a lot tougher and
um,
but anyways,
you know what was funny?
So once we went to winnow,
this buddy of mine called it,
he was just going like,
dude,
you know,
as long as you said before,
Garappolo got engine,
he goes,
I,
if he goes to,
went to,
that's fine.
I just don't want him to go for no,
because any every fucking dope out there.
It's going to be like,
you see,
it's just a system.
You could put anybody at dairy,
they were word,
which is basically what boob or a boomer fucking Esiason said.
He even said that.
It just boggles my fucking mind.
Some dope tweeted that to me.
You know,
like they sit there and they look like beating a rebuilding team during the
second fucking week of the season is the same as being down with a minute and a
half left in the super bowl.
You know the time when other people fucking puke up that Campbell's soup.
You know
other people who are shaped like a pencil who crush it in November fold during
that fucking time.
You know,
there's very few.
Tom Brady's out there.
Very few Eli Manning's Eli Manning.
You want,
you want to beat Eli Manning?
Play him in September.
He's like a sleepy dog.
Just fucking lay it on a poet.
It bores the man.
What is this?
A regular season game?
We've got another 40 Ah,
wake me up when the playoffs are at stake,
then all of a sudden the giants got it when the last six games and then that
fucking guys,
he just see fire in his eyes while he,
who's kidding?
Who?
We never has fired his eyes.
He just,
I don't know what the fuck he does.
He knows how to turn it on and to fucking sit here with disrespect.
Tom Brady like that and this is nothing to,
they always have this stupid Matt Cassel analogies like Matt Cassel it and he to
11 and five can I finally debunk that?
Okay,
for all you fucking fantasy football,
Buffalo Wild Wings wearing a Jersey fucking dopes out there.
Who?
Fucking high five Gallup sideways.
He told my fantasy t I activated them today.
Here's the thing.
For the fucking 90000000th time,
the whole Matt Cassel thing,
Matt Cassel took over a fucking team that went 16 and old in the regular season
was one get one fucking play away from going 19 and oh the next year he's under
center.
They went 11 and five and for you fucking dope out there who can't do math?
He won five less gates.
Okay?
Okay.
There's sit and miss the fucking playoffs.
That's what he did with an 18 in one fucking team.
He went 11 and five missed the playoffs.
Thank God we didn't go 10 and six do the math,
fantasy football play in fucking dopes.
He would have gone five and 11
all right.
You guys don't remember when he got,
he got traded to Kansas City.
Okay.
And then all of a sudden became mortal again.
You don't remember that.
And I know
she going to say,
hey,
we'll play with your players.
Oh,
I got an answer for you.
Joe Montana.
Joe Montana went to the Kansas city chiefs and you know what happened when he
went there?
The Kansas City chiefs went to the playoffs.
All right,
you fucking morons.
Here's the deal.
Mick Jagger needs Keith Richards.
Bill Walsh needed Joe Montana.
All right,
it,
Bill Bellacheck is not going to win a fucking super bowl with Garappolo.
At least not in the forest.
I mean,
who knows what that kid can do,
but at least not in the first fucking,
it's so fucking stupid.
Well,
tell you right now we check is so good.
You could put anybody,
your character going to work
cause we beat the dolphins the second week.
We're too went,
oh that's it.
That's it.
Somehow now we're never going to lose a fucking game again.
So you know that chatter is going to happen because there's this buffalo wild
wings people all the way up to guys like Dan Shaughnessy.
He's going to say it.
You don't think God Garappolo got hurt because Dan Shaughnessy,
you know the fucking Benedict Arnold of Boston sports,
he's all does that man lives to try to stir up a controversy to distract the
hometown team.
He doesn't give a fuck.
You know what I mean?
He's,
he's like,
skip Bayless before skip Bayless.
It's just,
you just listened to the man.
It's just like,
dude,
you're just literally just saying Shit,
aren't you?
Um,
you just say and shit to say shit.
And I'll tell you right now because you believed in me.
I dared to try.
Um,
Okay.
That's one of the worst.
I mean,
other than just racist things,
like if you just get away from that,
if we just like Deuce chills as I learned that from OPEC and the OPD entity
show,
I always give him credit for that expression.
It's just right up there.
I mean,
that's a top five all time.
The next time my wife compliments me,
I'm going to say that to her because she believed in me.
I dared to try.
Um,
these are stories that need to be told.
We're storytellers and with us,
without us giving people a voice,
you know,
what else is great?
You know,
as the Emmys,
I think the Emmy's got scared by all this shit.
The Oscars God,
you know,
and what was funny is as many people of color,
that one,
one of the funniest shots all night long was when,
you know,
if you looked,
if they just would like do a shot behind Jimmy Kimmel and you saw the front row,
it looked like a great mix of everybody.
But when they did the,
the shot was when they'd come back from commercial and you saw the whole crowd.
It was like from the thousands row up to the third row,
it was all white.
It was like,
okay,
it looks like a foreign,
a concert from the back row all the way,
like the third row.
But if they did it the way they shot it,
they front end loaded.
Okay.
Like the 15 black people that were there,
they just had them all right in front.
Some Asian people and all that.
But all the way to the back,
I was joking with Nia like you,
if you live in New York City,
every once in a while you go into one of those Bodegas sets either deal with
drugs that just going out of business and it looks like it's fucking stocked
with food and you grab that one can of food and you look in this like this and
behind the shelves there's like,
there's nothing behind that can,
this is just completely empty.
So I did get some laughs while watching it.
Um,
and I got it.
Be honest with you,
most of the shows I really,
you know,
I mean that people versus Oj was awesome.
All the was,
I'm just teasing the actress.
It's just fucking funny watching them get all Jesus Christ the weight of every
fucking thing that they say.
It's just unbelievable.
It's just like that inside the actor's studio when that fucking guy just sits
there.
Like,
I hope you realize the presence of greatness that we are.
You know,
just like Jesus Christ.
Dude,
you fucking get pretending to be a fireman.
Relax.
Um,
it was so brave.
It was such a brave performance.
You know what I mean?
There's this fucking people update at the end of buildings,
skyscrapers and shit.
Oh,
those guys who go up and they change.
You ever see those things?
Might my palms literally sweat watching these people?
They climb all the way up those towers to change the fucking light,
the little light bulb at the top of the tower at the top of the fucking building
so no plane can see it at night.
And they get that part where they unhooked the safety thing.
Jesus Christ it putting on 20 pounds and wearing a wig is brave.
What the fuck is that?
You can't die acting canyon.
Well,
I guess you can't.
There's ways to die as an actor,
right?
The fake gun on set turns out it's got,
you know,
you put it up to your head is that they believe fucking bring a helicopter.
People have died on set.
So no disrespect to them.
Um,
anyways,
plowing ahead.
So I'm glad to finally get to address that stupid Matt Cassel thing.
Okay,
no disrespect to that castle.
He was a solid quarterback,
but Jesus Christ to fucking act like,
well,
Hey,
I'm 80 parents,
Matt Castle or Tom Brady,
the patriots still go to six winning four out of six.
C'Mon,
C'mon people.
You know,
the reality is,
is what it is,
is she fucking hate the Patriots and if there's any remote angle for you guys to
criticize the Patriots,
you try and find it and I'm going to,
I'm going to go even further I think all right,
20 years.
So now when they look back at it and everybody can just fucking let it go,
you know,
even like,
like the most harshest red sox fan that hated Derek Jeter,
you know,
who's getting hope because the guy was great,
even at the end of his career,
even you couldn't hate the guy.
I think 20 years from now.
That's how good look at Tom Brady is.
It's going to take 20 years after he retires.
When they look back on the pettiness.
And the patheticness of and the level of this fucking suspension.
You know,
I think in the end,
Jim say finally it's going to be exposed for the fucking crybaby that he truly
is.
You know what I mean?
It's just really hard with ESPN now.
How they try to fucking just blow everything up.
Like,
you know,
it's funny,
the whole Colin Kaepernick sitting down
during the,
uh,
the national anthem,
the way they sat there and they just tried to fan the fucking flames of that.
Then they had the camera for the whole song on a couple of guys taken a knee.
There's like 45 guys standing up to guys taking a need,
another guy sitting down.
It's about police brutality.
We get it right,
but they're going to sit there and fade out.
It just,
it drives me nuts.
They talk about that last week though of just how everybody just turns it into
themselves.
Like those,
uh,
moments like that.
Like they just won't keep it on topic,
which is,
this is protesting police brutality and just wanting a conversation in figuring
out what are we doing?
What are you doing?
How can we make this better?
Because neither one of us wants this result overall because overall people are,
I think they're good.
All right,
and there are scumbag,
you know,
obviously on both sides or whatever.
Maybe you can fucking weed them out.
I don't know how to do.
I knew there's no,
for them this basically there is no solution to it.
I don't have any.
Right,
but what is funny is I was listening to this radio show,
I can't remember if I talked about this last Thursday,
was fucking hilarious and it was five white guys talking about it and by the end
of it,
like there was no talking about police brutality.
Why would there be this five white dudes talking about it?
And they literally go,
well,
what about when,
when you're raw,
when you're at home,
when you were at home watching the game and the national anthem comes on,
should,
should you stand up then
okay.
No,
you sure they were all afraid to say no.
you shouldn't.
If you want to,
you can,
but you're in your house,
which great about being in your house is you finally get to be 100% you,
which means you're going to,
you're barely gonna have clothes on.
Okay.
You're going to be verbally abusing people.
You're going to be drinking a beer.
You're going to say all kinds of fucked up shit to your television,
which is why,
by the way,
if you have one of those smart TVs,
if you ever want to run for president,
you have got to put a piece of tape over that thing.
And I don't know how to turn off the listening device,
but I believe my p the paranoid me,
I believe that they are video.
If you leave it on there,
videotaping everything that they can get and recording everything that they
could get so they can build this.
Okay.
They can make this movie trailer about you.
You know,
some day,
well,
you're either a fucking hero.
Oh,
you're just a complete piece of shit.
Well,
I guess they couldn't show it.
MMM.
I guess it would only show it.
If you didn't do what they wanted you to do,
then they would just leak it out and be like,
new shocking video discovered today on the Internet.
Have an eight year old,
whatever Obama of whatever saying,
listen this while he was watching
eight ways to fuck your mother.
I never know the name of it.
The Big Bang theory.
All right.
That went off the rails,
didn't it?
29 minutes.
A Yammer inbuilt.
Jesus fucking Christ.
You know,
some days the podcast is hard.
Other days it's easy.
But I just want to say to everybody who will listen
because you dare to download.
I dare to try.
Ooh.
Um,
all right,
let's,
let's get some of the advertising out of the way for this week.
So,
um,
okay.
You know,
as much as I am shitting on,
Jim are saying,
I do not hate the colts on any level.
Um,
I was watching them play and uh,
it's just fucking,
it's just such a great fucking uniform.
They're always going to be the Baltimore Colts to me.
And uh,
Andrew luck is the shit whenever he runs.
He's like a hybrid of Steve Young and John Elway and um,
it's just a fucking Broncos there.
Look at greater and greater like deck.
Now those guys,
if I was to one,
no,
it's the Patriots to tour now and we beat the panthers and then we beat,
we beat the colts.
I would be pretty excited.
Um Oh,
I got to talk about the ramps when I get back here.
All right,
here we go.
A couple of reads here.
People where to go?
One,
two,
three,
four,
five,
five.
All right,
but you know what?
People are learning that I can't read out loud to the copies real quick.
All right,
here we go.
track early.
Everybody tracker,
smart cars,
smart phones,
smart house technology has made everything wicked smart doctor.
But losing your stuff.
Make smart people feel really stupid.
Kid Track and make slews and thanks is thingy the past Joe tracker is a coin
size device that you can just put on the back of somebody's neck.
Is it coin size device?
I'm actually,
I'm not supposed to say that.
You're not supposed to use this to track people.
Draggers at coin size device that locates misplaced keys,
wallets,
bags,
computers,
anything in seconds.
Just pair of tracker,
do your smartphone.
I just pictured like trying to find your computer.
They find it in two seconds and you look over and it's some big duty.
Could beat the shit out of you and you just like,
well there it is.
I know where it is and I guess I'm not getting it back.
Just pair of tracker to your smart phone.
Attach it to anything in.
Fine.
It's precise location with the tap of a button.
It's that fucking easy.
Lose your phone,
press the button on tracker and your phone rings.
Even if even when it's on silent.
Oh,
that's not creepy at all.
How do you guys do that?
How do you turn my phone on?
Is this like some side fucking project by the CIA or something like that?
Why would they need extra money?
What would they do?
You know,
maybe they're going to buy like 50th anniversary,
like get smart shoe phones,
you know,
and the government doesn't have enough money to pay for it.
Well,
you're gonna have to figure out another way.
what if we came up with a company that just track shit?
You know?
All right,
with 1.5 million devices tracker is the largest crowd gps network and the world
world world.
So your last item shows up on the map.
Even if it's mile away,
aren't we?
Get it.
Never lose anything.
Gamma tracker,
you've established this listeners to this show.
Get a special discount of 30% off your entire order.
Go spelled t,
h e wow.
They're really talking down to you guys,
spelled t h e tracker,
t r a C K e r.com and enter Promo Code Burr.
The hardest thing you'll ever have to find is there a website once again,
go to tracker.com right now and it's Promo code birth for 30% off your entire
order.
Again,
that's tracker.com Promo Code Bird.
Ah,
here we go.
Boop,
boop,
me undies.
Me undies.
Pat's a fucking two n oh,
but dude,
dude,
dude.
Brds me undies.
Where the fuck ed go?
We're gonna go for rand fucking Oh,
we'll have our balls dragging in tow,
but they'll feel soft cars there
me undies
underneath the fucking cops.
Oh yeah.
Tom Brady comes back in two weeks.
We really made it.
Fuck Jim Earth.
Say,
I hope he wears a jock strap.
All alright.
Whether you're wearing a suit or sweats,
he spent almost 24 hours a day in your underwear.
Unless you're a fucking pervert and you're free balding.
But instead of making a statement like Superman's tights under his everyday
clothes,
um,
your underwear is probably boring.
Well,
me undies is here to change that.
They're here.
They're here to jazz up your fucking underwear.
Um,
all right.
Every pair of me undies is made by sustainable source modal modal of fabric
that's twice as soft as coffin,
allegedly.
Nothing can describe the fit and feel of me undies once it gets up against your
under carriage.
You know what I mean?
You'll start doing scissor kicks just to enjoy it.
Uh,
I mean,
you know what those are,
but once you try them on,
maybe lesbians can do that,
put it on and just do that little bump and grind up against each other.
Like,
oh my God,
it's even more amazing.
Uh,
but once you try them on,
you'll understand they're called the why.
They're called the world's mold.
The world's world's world's most comfortable underwear.
And if you don't love your first pair of underwear,
they're free.
No questions asked.
Beyond these has dozens of styles and limited edition prints to help you make a
statement with your underwear limited ditch.
Should prints check out the Rod Stewart from 1978.
Uh,
whether anyone can see them or not.
Remember Superman.
All right.
Shipping is free and the United States and Canada.
And he could save up $8 up to $8 a pair with me undies script scription plant.
Get the subscription or a single pair.
Get 20% off your first order.
When you go to me undies.com that's [inaudible] dot com slash burr for 20% off
your first order.
[inaudible] dot com slash [inaudible] all right.
Oh Jesus.
Dollar Shave Club do you do all his shave club keeps getting better.
This is the last one.
And then I'll go back to the podcast.
Uh,
they sat it four years ago by delivering their amazing affordable raises and
they've grown to over 3 million members,
uh,
who no longer overpay for a quality morning shave and now new members can get
their first pair for free.
Dollar Shave Club is so much more than razors.
They have a mission,
they want you to look good,
smell good and feel your best.
And they've,
they've been investing millions in Rad r and D,
whatever that is developing their own original grooming formulas,
fear,
face,
hair and body.
Yeah.
They also want to make zillions of dollars and get some horse.
Let's not forget about that.
All right.
This stuff is amazing.
Pre and post shave formulas,
skin protection formulas,
killer hairstyling products and literally the most amazing soap and body wash
she'll ever use.
The store experience is awful.
All the stuff looks the same.
There's too many options and no one's there to help you find the products that
are right for you.
Do you have any idea why you picked the shampoo or body wash should do?
Seriously,
just get all your grooming stuff shipped from dollar shave club.
Yeah,
you never have to fucking go there again.
Every time you walk into rite aid and one of those places,
there's a zillion fucking people there and one old person trying to develop
pictures,
right?
And then the fat fuck wants to get ice cream.
You don't want to stand in that line.
Give it a try.
Once you get in there,
you'll see the products work.
Amazing.
The service is world class and there's no comp commitment,
no hidden fees.
You can cancel whenever you want.
Get your first month for free@dollarshaveclub.com slash [inaudible] just pay
shipping and it's only a few bucks.
That's dollar shave club.com/burr.
All right,
back to the podcast.
Let's talk about the ramps yet that that Dap Gudu Gudu oh by the way,
people waiting for me to talk about Formula One racing.
I didn't get a chance to see the race because I'm,
all of that shit is recorded on my teeth at home.
So,
um,
I guess when I go over there today to do the elliptical,
elliptical,
uh,
as I try to melt,
but what's left of this fucking belly off before my special,
um,
I'll sit down and watch it.
I heard it's an amazing race.
It was in Singapore,
which I've had the privilege of going to one time and doing a,
uh,
had a great time doing a show there.
So I'm looking forward to it.
I have somehow been able to avoid seeing who won.
And now that I've said that,
I know there's trolls out there,
so I will not be looking at any of my fucking devices today until I watch it.
So anyways,
let's talk about the Los Angeles Rams.
Oh,
the poor ramps,
the poor fucking ramps.
You know,
they fucking left La Memorial Coliseum in 1979.
I'm done with this town of sicky.
You bomb it dead.
You'll see.
I'm going to come back one day and you'll understand why you should have bought
me a new stadium.
Right?
And then they went down to Anaheim,
bright fell in with the new crowd,
you know,
and they promise them a new stadium and they didn't give him one.
And then they were like,
well to hell with you,
you're just like my parents.
And then they moved to Saint Louis and they got to still another Shitty fucking
stadium.
But they still,
despite that,
they learned to overcome and they won.
They won a Superbowl in 1999.
The greatest fucking show on turf,
right?
Of course they lost to the Patriots in 2001.
But you know,
that's life.
You have your good days and your bad days.
All right?
Isn't that right there Ricky parole,
the dynasty brigades.
Rarely is that what happened?
Reiki or Reiki.
Um,
anyway,
so now like all these years later,
it's like they,
it's the back in the La more memorial coliseum.
They,
they've,
they've fuckin come back 37 years later to move back in with their fucking
parents while they get this shit together.
It's like they went through a divorce,
they found love and Saint Louis,
they thought it was great.
And then like 20 years into that marriage,
you know,
the partner came out and just said,
listen,
I'm gay.
You know,
it's not that I didn't love you,
but I just need to explore this part of me.
I need to be who I am.
And the ramps were like,
what the fuck?
And that they had to move back in with their parents while they get their shit
together,
but they still got that Superbowl money.
So they got a new stadium.
So it's the next couple of years.
It's like a sick Coptic and there's a great,
there's,
you know what,
there's a premise right there for set cub.
Somebody was married for 20 fucking years.
There are other partner comes out,
says that they're gay,
so they got to move back in with their parents.
You keep the gay character there,
so you win an Emmy,
right?
Right.
Because you,
did you write it?
I had the courage to say it
right.
You get a fucking Emmy,
Jesus Christ
that could come on right after the Big Bang theory.
Somebody for the love of God go out and right there.
Um,
just God knows I'm not gonna.
anyways,
that's what the ramps are.
What the fuck would that be called?
You've got the classic moving in with you.
That's great.
You get the classic,
move it back in home to your hometown with your parents.
But because you're addressing,
um,
somebody being gay than the critics got to go easy cause they don't want to look
homophobic.
We all these fucking,
this,
this trope again.
Oh that's perfect.
That's fucking perfect.
Right?
And then you throw an Asian character in there,
a couple of people of color,
right?
Get a nice mix Casco.
And like they had back in the 70s,
remember fish,
they are a young Willis was on that show yet.
Sanford,
it's sun yet the Jeffersons.
You had all these great fucking shows.
And then the 80s came and Reagan came and he said,
ah,
take the solar panels off the White House,
make the sitcoms white again.
Right.
Jesus Christ.
And then what happened?
What was the follow up?
Yeah,
those six people dancing in the fountain in the 90s we went it a billable by the
elbow,
the widest fucking song that's ever been written.
We knew to do.
Do,
do,
do Baba Baba Baba papel bullpen and then they'll go right.
How do I know that?
Cause I got a lady in my life,
I'll be honest with you,
I actually,
Joey's character,
Joey's fucking hilarious on friends.
I haven't seen that many of them.
But you could get through them cause she knew Joey was going to say something
funny and Jenna Fairness Aniston was fucking smoking hot.
Not that,
not that still isn't.
You know what I mean?
I don't want to have to apologize to the ages and crowd here,
but you get somehow get through it.
Like Joey would say something to help you get through the episode,
but I got to tell you when they would dance in the fountain,
like I always just thought that that was a network note where they were just
like,
all right,
you motherfuckers,
you wanna fucking all gang up together and negotiate and hold us over a barrel
for,
we'll give you,
we'll give you a you a million dollars an episode,
but you know what?
You're going to dance in a fucking fountain to the widest song ever in a party.
He's going to die when you watched,
when you really watch the opening credits of that,
you can seek the girls don't give a fuck,
right?
But you can see it and the guys,
you can see a part of them dies each season when they do that,
we ain't gaining in and really we got to be in the FFO.
Why did they have to dance?
Okay,
let's plow ahead here anyways,
clear.
What are you doing?
Why are you staring at me?
Huh?
You burn out your head,
your food,
your tail wagon on the ground.
You had your food,
right?
Cleo or I don't have time to do this,
let's get back to the ramps.
So they fucking come back their first home opener.
You got to love that.
They go back to the,
the blue and the yellow uniforms,
which is exactly what they should be wearing.
That that should not be their third jersey.
That should be their first Jersey yet all the fans were in the old school
fucking pad Hagen and in Eric Dickerson Jersey.
It was even Dickerson.
Never played in that stadium,
but it was fucking great.
It was so great to see.
And then who look,
who was the cross who was across the street,
who is on the other sideline?
It was so perfect.
All Pete Carroll.
Oh,
pistol Pete Carroll returning to the scene of the crimes.
Right.
I would say I would,
if I was him,
I would have been nervous,
you know,
like,
am I going to get arrested by the fucking NCAA?
You know what halftime and finally get to question me.
Um,
but you know,
he was just doing what everybody else did.
It's fine.
I actually know something.
The,
uh,
USC really got fucking think got screwed over in that,
take it back a Heisman trophy.
I mean,
come on.
Because what USC was doing,
what everybody else does it that level.
College football is fucking filthy.
Nobody got fucked over more than the buckeyes though at time of those guys.
What do they sign?
Jersey so they could get free tattoos.
Um,
something like that.
I Dunno,
Bill,
you could look it up.
You can maybe get your fucking ducks in a row,
figure out what's going on.
Uh,
this is one of these weeks.
I just have too much shit to talk about.
Um,
I had an amazing fucking time when I was in Durham,
uh,
playing the Carolina theater.
What a fucking gym that places the crowds were great.
Um,
my fucking act
is still,
for some reason an hour and 50 minutes long.
I got to figure out how to cut this thing down.
Um,
but I still had a great time and some of the greatest food I've ever had when
I've been on the road.
I didn't realize that Duke University was in Durham.
I had no idea.
And I was just walking around going like,
why the fuck in this random town
that's,
you know,
like half hour away from Raleigh,
the state capitol has all this great food,
this is incredible.
And they just kept seeing Duke Blue Devil gear,
people wearing hats and shit.
I was just like,
oh,
I'm an idiot.
This is a college town.
And um,
I'm actually,
I've got to give a shout up to a couple of places.
We hate this place to federal be,
give a go there.
They got these black bean burger sliders that are incredible.
And then I went to arguably the best soul food restaurant I've ever been to and
I've been to a lot of bad ones,
a lot of bad ones over the years I've been talked into their man,
why people don't know how to cook.
You have to season your food and Blah,
blah,
blah blah.
So you fucking go in there and what do you get?
You get a weak ass waffle and some dry fucking chicken and there is nothing
fucking worse than dry chicken.
Chicken is the greatest taste in food there is.
Everybody loves it.
It's fucking delicious.
And there's nothing better than when it's cooked right.
But when it's dried out
to eat dried chicken,
it's literally a job.
Like your job gets sore.
You know,
like I bet in the future when people want to avoid getting a double chin,
they're going to have the dry chicken workout and you just eat half a fucking
chicken that's dry.
Did you just sit there chewing that shit and you develop these jaw muscles that
prevents you from getting like that?
Joey Ramone,
you know,
the thing that he had with it just goes Chin right to the center,
your chest.
Um,
the pellet kitchen.
so anyways,
this place was called dames.
D a.
M.
E Apostrophe s.
N.
When you go there,
I'm actually going to,
I'm going to go online right now and I'm going to get to the fucking menu.
You got to try their fucking chicken cutlet.
They had a chicken cutlet with this barbecue sauce and Dean del Rey who fucking
crushed it all week.
Um,
he,
uh,
he got the shrimp,
so he had this hot sauce.
So I had this barbecue sauce to put it in and I also had um,
this hot sauce to put it in.
Oh my God,
look,
just look at that fucking food.
A chicken and waffle inspiration.
What's the one I got the option like the dames option because you could actually
pick out Dame's daily deal.
Right.
Serve Tuesday.
Now that's not it.
Ah,
I'll never be able to find it.
It was basically something that was,
you could,
it was an option that you could,
it was the Dame something or other.
But what was cool was you got to pick out the chicken.
You want it,
the part of the chicken.
So I went with the chicken cutlet
and I got a waffle and we actually took it to go and brought it back to the
hotel room.
So we ate it about 15 minutes later.
So it's still,
it traveled great.
I can't imagine if I actually just sat there and ate it.
Like there was already a line out the door and I heard the guy was going to open
another one.
Once again,
it's called a dames,
chicken and waffles in a Durham,
North Carolina.
It was fucking amazing.
And uh,
and then the bar,
we w we would go to,
we went to the federal and they just had all these great beers and um,
yeah,
it was amazing.
There was a couple of beers that I tried.
I had one that was actually nine point something percent alcohol.
Took a picture of it.
It had like a fucking,
I had like almost looked like the rolling stones except a tongue wasn't out,
you know,
just had like lips
is called hell yes ma'am.
Belgian style golden and a,
if you Google a picture of it
and you look on the can,
32 full ounces,
9.2% alcohol cause you know beer is going to give you a belly so you might as
well get to it.
You want to drink a beer?
That seal right there.
Fred.
They had some great local beers.
It was another one that I had every night.
Just had like one.
And,
um,
we had a great time.
And,
uh,
it turned out the,
North Carolina tar heels football team was at home against James Madison
University.
And I was like,
fuck it man.
I gotta go.
I got to go.
We went over there,
had a great time.
It was hot as balls.
We sat at the top of the stadium,
you know,
so we'd have a little bit of shade.
It was still a great time and a absolutely no defense in that game.
And the first half we saw eight touchdowns total.
It was 35,
21.
MMM.
Every way you could fucking score on offense,
flea flicker,
the fucking running back coming out of the backfield in just runs just a
sideline route and nobody picks him up.
And basically something that should have gone for six yards or maybe a pick six
if you sniffed it out.
Went for like 80 yard touchdown.
Um,
it was incredible.
Uh,
but um,
so that was,
and I was sitting there going,
wow,
that was like the,
that's the fourth or fifth ACC team I've seen.
Um,
out of all of them,
it was a,
let's see,
I've seen Boston College.
Okay.
North Carolina state.
When I went there for two semesters before they enclose the stadium member,
I sat on grass,
I had grass seats.
That's how long ago this was.
It was like 1987.
Um,
Jesus clear.
What do you got?
Fleas,
you and over there I've seen North Carolina tar heels and I seen the University
of Miami.
So slowly but surely with my OCD,
I'm going to,
I'm going to knock out the ACC eventually.
I would like,
by the time I look up in my 70,
still gone to almost every major program out.
Um,
and I know it sounds fucked up,
but it's,
it's fun as hell and it,
it,
it makes doing the road kind of easy,
you know,
like,
um,
I've seen a,
I've seen like what I it by the end of this,
okay,
this football season,
let's see.
And this year I'm going to see Carolina,
I'm going to see Nebraska,
I'm going to see Florida Lsu.
And uh,
I think I might hang out in Nashville and go to that Vanderbilt game.
And then I'll,
I've seen like in an like 18 or 20 college football teams,
but,
um,
I don't know.
I've kind of gotten into that shit.
Like being able to name like obscure divisions.
Like what's the one,
is it mountain west
where it's like Wyoming,
New Mexico,
Nevada.
You went LV,
air force,
Hawaii and then it's all the state teams.
Boise State,
Colorado State,
Utah State,
San Jose State,
Fresno state,
San Diego state.
I think I missed one in there.
Um,
and going to those ones,
everybody wants to go to the big house and Shit.
You go to some of those dudes,
you got kicked fucking great games,
great games.
And then what's cool is you might get lucky and there might be like the next
Randy Moss who for whatever he did something in high school.
I got blamed for some shit or just fucked up in school.
And you get to see,
you know,
some great player down there.
You May just stumble upon somebody who's just completely dominating,
clear.
Why are you so fucking navy today,
man?
What's going on with you?
Um,
it's coming up here.
Just putting a head right in my lap.
Hey,
hey.
Hey.
Watch the wires.
All right,
I've got to wrap this thing up.
Let me,
uh,
I haven't done the questions yet.
Um,
oh,
by the way,
how many walk people are going to score a touchdown and drop the ball before
they get into the end zone?
If I was a coach,
I would just be like,
I don't give a fuck what you do once you get in the end zone,
but,
but move the ball forward.
Stop doing this,
dropping it behind you.
Jesus fucking Christ.
It's like almost every week now at the pro or the college level,
somebody goes and does it and then they have this shot.
Fuck a look on their face.
Like they've never seen somebody do it.
Uh,
how bad did what,
what was that team was at the longhorns that could completely fucked over.
They said that they didn't recover the ball.
What do you mean?
The ball was just laying there and the guy went over and he picked it up.
Was that the game?
Was a California game?
Was a California against texts,
cal vers,
Texas.
Um,
but I just saw the highlights so I didn't hear when they blew the whistle or
what happened.
I don't know if the refs fucked up like that,
but uh,
it seemed like Texas totally get fucked over on that one.
So anyway,
so let me get to the uh,
the questions here for this week.
Um,
okay.
All right.
Where were the questions?
Content for this week.
All right.
Weight loss and nutrition.
Yeah.
Hey Bill,
a little tip for you.
Healthy Nutrition program preparation to do this special out too.
I could use all the help I could get dude,
48 some motherfucker,
man.
Um,
on your last podcast you mentioned during that first week of a healthy diet,
you can lose a lot of weight,
I think in kilograms.
I don't know how much you've lost,
uh,
lost in pounds,
ears.
Here's the tip.
You are indeed able to lose a lot of weight during the first week,
but it's not,
but it is not fat.
It's just water.
What happens is while you're eating unhealthy,
your body absorbs a lot of water.
If you eat carbs,
pastas,
rice,
potatoes,
fruits,
your body will keep on absorbing water,
uh,
or make you look and feel bigger,
which is good when you're building muscle.
If you want to look good on your special cut carbs a little bit,
but eat vegetables and meat a few times a day,
your bottle will be forced to burn fat and it will not absorb so much water.
You can lose a lot quickly.
I hope it helps.
Love to show an Antwerp,
go fuck yourself.
Polish guy working in Luxembourg and living in Belgium.
Okay.
Um,
all right.
I'll give the kind of sounds like the Atkins Diet,
which I always get worried about like a,
you know,
I guess I'll just eat healthy.
I just remember when the Atkins Diet came out.
People like Doh,
Jack can eat bacon all day and I keep losing weight and it's like,
dude,
you're not going to want to look at your plumbing after that one.
I can eat bacon all day.
All right,
new car.
But now there's this new diet where people are just like,
it's just sugar,
cut out sugar and flour and then you can drink butter.
I drink butter in the morning and it helps me burn fat.
This is whole new thing.
Who the fuck knows?
Like literally like how to lose weight is like,
you know,
it's like religions,
you know what I mean?
Every fucking one of them has some Zany fucking way,
but they all basically go to the same thing that you go to heaven and heaven I
guess is losing your fucking weight in this shit.
But I have no idea.
Anyways,
new Carlin Album,
dear Billy yogurt legs.
Are you excited for this new Carland album?
I haven't even heard about it.
Oh yeah.
Wait a minute.
I did here.
They thought it was too harsh.
He recorded it before nine 11 and they didn't release it because it had material
that was definitely not appropriate for what was going on at the time.
I've heard great things,
but who knows.
Thanks for the laughs.
Oh,
absolutely.
When is it coming out?
I got to buy that on vinyl.
Um,
I'm absolutely excited about that.
He is a,
I mean,
as far as greatest of all time.
I have Richard Pryor and George Carlin just for their bodies of work and how,
you know,
they truly took everything.
Lenny Bruce,
Mort,
Saul and all those guys did before them.
Woody Allen,
Bill Cosby,
and they just took it into the modern era.
Um,
yeah.
And kind of like,
I don't know that anybody has really gone beyond it.
Like they just sort of,
they just blow
it wide open.
I just don't feel like you can do it better than those guys.
All right.
Hillary Clinton.
Hey Bill.
A legit question.
Do you think Hillary Clinton is healthy enough to be president?
Yes.
She seems like she's in really rough shape now.
She,
they just overreacting.
She gets,
she fucking,
she's running for president for a year and a half.
She's under tremendous amount of fucking stress that's going to happen.
All right.
Don't you think?
Don't you remember the time fucking Bush the first Bush like puked on himself
and did a fucking face plant when he was in Japan?
He was fine.
Um,
don't you think if Gary Johnson got on the debates,
it would steer things in the right direction.
Now it would probably give Trump the white house.
He lines up with Bernie on 80 per 3% of his views.
But because he's a libertarian,
the youth won't jump on board like they did Bernie and he has a legit shot at
winning.
Only 4% of the u s voted in the primaries.
I checked all these stats,
so go ahead and call me out if you want.
Not on,
I can't because I don't check any stats.
It's your tendency to call out stats.
So I've made sure to look them up.
I think Hillary has been in,
uh,
in the game too long and it's just torn her body apart.
And also what do you think about Colin powers saying that Bill Clinton has been
dicking Bimbos all over the house in a leaked email?
Uh,
well that's not surprising.
I mean,
everybody knew that.
Okay.
Everybody knows that.
Everybody knows that about that guy.
And that's why Hillary Clinton is just fucking weird to me.
The fact that she's still with the guy because you know what,
you know,
it's a business relationship and that has that I will fucking do anything like
Hillary Clinton in different areas is just as terrifying is Trump.
But I dunno,
just this overt fucking racist group of people.
And the fact that the yelling out the n word,
uh,
you know,
at Trump rallies,
at least they have it on video that that happened and Trump never fucking
addressed it is really,
uh,
it's just,
I could never get behind that guy.
Um,
it's just too fucking,
it's just,
it's too fucking depressing watching people.
Did you,
did you hear that?
I've fucked dead and we're that fucking guy.
And it's just like,
dude,
like the level of intellect that Obama has versus what you have,
the fact that you'd sit there and try to reduce them like that,
it's just so fucking pathetic and sad.
And the fact that now that those kinds of people feel it,
they have,
they have a fucking voice and God knows I'm not just singling out that one guy.
Cause you go on any youtube video that remotely has anybody who isn't fucking
white in it and you can't go more than fucking scroll down one page before it
turns into this horrific.
Like I just,
I just for the life of me don't understand why people are racist.
I just don't,
I don't get it.
I don't just,
I'm not saying that you
don't have fucking racist thoughts,
you know,
as far as I do them too in this bit,
now I'm kind of going to burn it.
He just like late at night that basically I'm a cool guy when the sun's up and
when the sun goes down,
the fear comes up,
you start thinking,
you start making snap judgments,
you know what I mean?
Everybody,
there's nobody.
Mother Teresa,
if she was scared with would think something fucked up that if it was actually
spoken,
she would own somebody in apologize,
apology.
And I think everybody fucking does it on,
on all sites.
Um,
but like,
I dunno
to sit there and think like,
yeah,
I'm going to type this and hit send and send this hateful fucking shit.
I don't know.
I find it incredibly depressing where if you,
if you're a standup comedian or if you're in,
um,
any sort of show business year in anything,
boy,
you travel
all right.
And you get to meet all different kinds of people.
You definitely get like a,
like almost like that astronaut experience.
You know,
like when they fly around and they get to stand back and look at the globe and
see how beautiful it is.
And then,
you know,
when they land they like start crying.
It like a stoplight.
Comedians get like sort of the same thing as you get to travel around and you
get to meet all these people and then,
you know,
you meet all these cool people,
but then you meet those people that never leave where they're from and then
their worldview,
you just want to be like,
it's,
it's not like that dude.
You just need to,
you know,
it's overwhelmingly fucking,
at least that's been my experience and it's fucking overwhelmingly depressing.
MMM.
Oh Man.
I got into it with somebody in Durham.
It came backstage,
dude,
it was fucking hilarious.
And,
uh,
oh my God,
I just,
that guy off
he goes,
well,
I'll just,
I wanted me to say what you're talking about.
It was,
how do you know,
how do you know I haven't had that experience?
And I said,
I could tell by your shirt.
And he just goes,
fuck you.
I got all fucking mad.
And just to be honest,
I wasn't shitting on the guide like the money he was making,
but I was talking about like being
uh,
like doing business for the United States in a foreign country.
Okay.
Being like a diplomat and that type of thing,
like that level thing.
And this guy showed up in these fucking,
this fucking shirt that like anybody who makes $40 a week,
this thing would be retired to the back of the closet.
He just show he just had the worst fucking shirt ever.
Uh,
angry,
angry motherfucker.
And I knew when the second he fucking walked in,
I fucking knew it when he goes like,
hey,
you really came down on the south,
you really came down in the south.
They said,
no,
it's was fucking around.
I love it down here.
So he immediately was doing that.
And then at some point when I was just chilling and just talking and he's gone,
you know,
he goes,
you're a gear.
He goes,
you're a good guy.
You know?
I like,
I like meeting good people.
That is code for this guy's feeling you out to
eventually say something racist amongst white people.
I like meeting good people.
Like,
what the fuck is that?
Oh really?
I like meeting bad.
I like meeting good people,
you know?
And then,
then it gradually,
then they go a little for good Christian people,
white people.
My Nia said last night,
she goes,
people who stand up during the national anthem and just it gradually,
they're feeling you out.
Yeah.
You know,
they've had a couple of pops a,
can I fucking drop a couple of n bombs around you?
MMM.
And I like meeting good people.
I felt like I was on the 700 club.
I was like,
dude,
you gotta get the fuck away from me.
All right.
And you know what I literally said to the guy was like,
dude,
you're fucking scare in me.
You see I got that.
You're making me fucking nervous.
And he kind of like backed off or whatever.
And then by the end of it,
you know,
I made the mistake,
I want to say I brought up politics and then it just went down that fucking
road.
And then I just literally,
I ended up tapping out.
I just got to the point,
I was like,
dude,
we're not going to agree.
This is stupid.
All right,
I don't want to do this.
you just got mad.
And then he tried to be like,
I am sad.
But you know what I liked about the guy?
I could see he was trying not to be a complete fucking lunatic.
But Dude,
I'm telling you this guy was wound tight.
This Gal with Y,
alright,
fuck fiance breaks it off.
Well you know something as much,
I don't even know what we need to read any further.
Thank God this person did that.
Then before you had to give away half of your shit.
Oh,
you had a kid and then you got this person had to be in your life for the rest
of your life.
Okay.
A Rouge Rouge tinted William,
my fiance,
was a bit of a case,
uh,
raised in an odd Christian cult,
escaped it,
uh,
in high school.
Spent most of her adult life working to support her family.
That was still in the cult.
Wow.
Eight years ago,
she met me six years ago.
We started a relationship.
It had its ups and downs,
and it was very loving and help change both of us for the better.
A year ago,
I finally proposed to her after we both became financially successful enough to
support our own household.
Uh,
okay.
So you both on equal ground.
That's good.
Shortly after that,
she lost one of her close friends then,
or grandfather.
Uh,
we got through it together and I thought it brought us even closer.
Everything was going peachy.
Right.
Well
at this time,
Cleo,
get up here.
Come here.
Get up here.
All right.
Just lay down.
Fucking relax.
All right,
well,
she fully reconverted.
Okay.
Everything's going a peachy.
Well,
at this time,
her family and her call leaders saw an opening and after a month or two she
started going back to the meetings.
Since I didn't want to be the closed minded guy and clingy near husband,
I let her go to those meetings.
Oh God.
Her beliefs are hers and mine are Mine and everyone's happy,
right?
Well,
she fully converted back.
Her family's threatened to shun her unless she married someone of the same faith
and sensor cult holes
proselytizing as one of the highest values,
highest virtue.
She tried to convert me.
I was going to guess that that's what that meant.
I can't say the word,
which is basically going out and getting more members.
I told her,
everyone of my experiences led me to believe that her beliefs weren't right for
me and a relatable at all to me.
I didn't see a future where I believed in the same religious things as she did,
but I did mine not.
I did mine her believing in different things,
but I didn't mind her believing in different things.
All right,
dude,
you've been totally honest.
You've,
you've handled this perfectly like a champ.
Then a month she called the wedding off and broke it off with me.
So I did the Duke thing,
drank,
worked out,
picked up new hobbies,
hobbies,
sorry.
I was thinking horse,
hobbies,
and vacation in the country.
Halfway,
uh,
half the world away.
I was relaxing on the beach and said country.
When someone from her cult approaches me and tries to convert me.
What the fuck?
Yeah.
What role you were in a different country.
Okay.
How do I get over the love of my life while still staying true to my,
to myself.
You're freckled cont thanks and go fuck yourself.
Visit Western Canada sometime soon.
A dude,
she did you a favor,
man.
She did you a fucking favor.
Get away from that Shit,
man.
I was like,
you can't be with somebody where their religious,
what their religion is telling them who to love.
All right.
Her now trying to get you convert is because she still loves you and that type
of thing.
So,
yeah,
I think your best case scenario of trying to get this woman back is to just
completely cut her out of your life.
Just ignore and get on with your life.
Who knows?
You might find someone else first.
It'd be I want to be with this person or she'll just finally be so fucking
miserable in that and realize that happiness she had with you and she'll go to
you,
but you can't go to her.
Cause if you go to her,
you're going to come off week and she's going to try to drag you down into the
fucking dark waters of that fucking cult.
So I say you get on with your life.
All right?
That's the best,
best case scenario for you to meet somebody new.
And,
uh,
that's the way you get over.
Just get on with your life,
you know,
and uh,
when you love somebody,
it doesn't totally go away,
but it definitely fades like a fucking old tattoo.
All right?
Um,
you know,
that's,
that's the best you can do.
You'll be fine,
man.
You'll meet somebody else and you know,
who knows dude,
even if she did fucking leave,
you know,
did you,
did you really want to be sitting there?
You know,
one morning you wake up,
the sun's coming up through your window when you look out and there's like a
couple of cold people standing there,
you know,
freaking yeah,
we just want to talk to her.
You don't need the Manson family.
No one where the fuck you are in approaching
Jesus Christ.
Dude,
please tell me.
I mean
sitting on a beach and denim,
that's like,
that's like invasion of the body snatchers.
Alright.
Greece in retirement.
Hey there,
Billy baklava,
my wife and I just got back from our honeymoon and grease up.
Congratulations.
Did you go to Santa Rini?
I hear it is fucking incredible.
Uh,
is that how you say,
ah,
we've never been there but we,
but knew we'd love it.
So we made sure to stay for a couple of weeks.
While there we were listening to your podcast and our balcony drinking wine and
you mentioned something about health and weight as you usually do.
And it made me think about how Greece was really put on earth for Bill Burr.
If you get to the right spot,
Bill,
I'm telling you,
the food is fresh,
the air is amazing,
and there's so much walking and feeling all good and feeling all around good.
Sorry.
Uh,
I think you'd really enjoy the pace here.
I know you just got back from Capri.
Uh,
but you should consider grease to next time you go away with Nia.
My wife and I already want to retire here in 20 years where 30,
uh,
you're going to retire in 20 years.
Jesus,
that's amazing.
Uh,
I hope you make it and hope you never hurt anybody to get there but help you
make it.
Uh,
would you ever leave the states?
If we have kids,
it may be difficult,
but we maintain some sub,
some semblance of a plan.
It could happen,
happened and he thoughts in the pros or cons of that?
Um,
well the thing about when you leave the good Ole USA is you're leaving the good
ole USA to great fucking country and I love it.
Um,
and secondly,
wherever you go,
you're always going to be considered a foreigner.
And people don't mind tell tourists when you come over there and you're spending
money,
but now when you're not leaving and you're taking jobs away from other people,
all of a sudden the Trump people over there don't like you and you're going to
have to deal with that and your kids are going to have to deal with that.
Uh,
so I dunno,
I would continue to visit.
That's what I would do.
But I'm not telling you what to do either.
You know what I mean?
If you want to fucking live over there,
if I was going to live anywhere,
I would live in France and I would live just outside of Paris.
It's someplace quiet.
And I would,
um,
I would become totally fluent,
but I would miss,
I would miss the United States.
I mean,
I love it here,
man.
I mean,
I'm not like you,
you,
you could go live somewhere else.
I can't.
Um,
so yeah,
I mean,
if the,
if that feels right,
there's a lot of people that do it.
You know,
people moved down to Costa Rica,
a lot of conspiracy theorist and that type of shit.
So,
um,
I dunno,
but Greece has definitely,
Greece and Spain are definitely on the list.
I'd like to see as many places as I possibly can,
um,
in my lifetime if that's possible.
Cleo,
knock it off.
Hello.
Oh,
okay.
Jesus Christ.
When she fucked him,
puts the bad air ups barriers up.
I get all nervous.
Um,
hey,
you're going to take her out.
Oh,
well Chloe,
I'll look at you did.
All right.
And yeah,
I got to wrap this thing up and then I got to go to work.
Um,
all right,
I got to read a couple of advertisings here.
Everybody all simply safe.
Everybody.
Thousands of people seeking home security get ripped off every day.
And the home security industry wants you to believe it's your only option.
They have hoards of salesmen out there trying to scare you into signing one of
their longterm contracts.
You get stuck writing huge checks month after month.
No way out.
It's robbery by contract and it can cost you thousands,
but there's a better way to protect your home.
Simply safe home security,
simply safe,
has no contracts,
none.
You'll get award winning,
24,
seven protection named best in the industry,
security professionals watching,
ready to instantly send the police.
And it's just 1499 per month.
That's less than half of what most companies charge.
Protect your home the smart way.
Uh,
protect your home,
the smart way visits simply safe.
Uh,
bird.com go right now.
And you'll also get free shipping on your order and a free key chain remote
where $25 it takes only a minute.
That's simply safe.
bird.com simply safe bird.com and finally,
lastly,
but not leastly stamps.com trips to the post office.
It probably becomes second nature to you.
They seem easy because you've been doing them doing your mailing and shipping
that way for so long.
But think about all the hassles,
man.
Dropping what you're doing,
driving,
they're finding parking,
the long line,
all of that shit.
Trying to,
Oh,
you put it in the wrong box.
This is priority,
not express,
waiting,
all of that shit.
There's a much better way to do it and that stamps.com stamps.com is the
easiest,
is easy and convenient is the easy and convenient way to get postage rates from
your desk.
They make it easy to get exact postage for any letter and he packaged any class
of mail the instant you need it.
No expensive postage meters to lease and no more trips to the post office.
You have to try it.
I use stamps.com whenever I send out any of my posters.
Hopefully that's going to be soon for that week during when I'm in a Washington
DC,
I'm thinking about making a poster sign up for free and I'm sorry,
sign up,
sign up for stamps.com and use my last name,
birth for this special offer,
a four week trial plus 110 to $10 bonus offer that includes postage and a
digital scale.
Don't wait.
Go to stamps.com before you do anything else,
click on the microphone@thetopofthehomepageandtypeinburrthatstamps.com enter
burr.
And lastly,
but not leastly.
If you want to donate to this podcast without having to spend a dime next time
you're going to go to amazon.com and buy something just swing by my website,
Bill.
Uh,
Bill bird.com.
Click on the podcast page,
click on the Amazon link.
I know that's three extra links.
Um,
whatever,
three x,
two little clicks of your mouse,
uh,
they will take you right to Amazon.
I get credit for driving traffic
there.
It doesn't increase the price of anything that you buy.
They kicked Lima,
me a little bit of money.
Donates to the podcast if you want to.
If not,
I get it.
Alright,
so that's the podcast for this week.
Patriots play on fucking Thursday.
I don't even know who they play him,
so fucking busy,
but I'm very excited to see if we can go three and l three and l with the third
stringer.
Who knows Garappolo might be back.
No idea.
No idea,
but it's a very exciting times in New England,
yet another amazing chapter.
Right.
And the never say die Boston sports that sent to everybody,
which is better than you.
I'm fucking with you,
but I am.
And join it.
All right.
Go fuck yourselves.
I'll talk to you on Thursday.
I'll check in on you.